evaluate the expression 5 Y to the
fourth minus y squared when y is equal
to three so every place we see a y here
we could just replace it with a 3 to
evaluate it so it becomes 5 times 3 to
the fourth power -3 squared all I did is
every time we saw Y here I put a 3 there
every time we saw why I put a 3 so what
does this evaluate to and we have to
remember our order of operations
remember parenthesis comes for sometimes
it's referred to as PEMDAS let me write
that down
PEMDAS PEMDAS P is for parentheses he is
for exponents m and D are for
multiplication and division and at
they're really at the same level of
priority and then addition and
subtraction at the same level if you
really want to do it properly should be
P E and then multiplication and division
are really at the same level an addition
and subtraction are at the same level
but what this tells us is that we do
parentheses first but then after that
exponentiation takes priority over
everything else here so we have to
evaluate these exponents before we
multiply anything or before we subtract
anything so the one exponent we'd have
to evaluate is 3 squared so just
remember 3 to the first is just 3 it's
just 3 times itself once so it's just 3
3 squared is equal to 3 times 3 3
multiplied by itself twice that's equal
to 9 3 to the third power is equal to 3
times 3 times 3 or you could view it as
3 squared times 3 so it'll be 9 3 times
3 is 9 9 times 3 is equal to 27 3 to the
fourth is equal to 3 times 3 times 3
times 3 so 3 times 3 is 9 3 times 3 is 9
so it's going to be the same thing as 9
times 9 so this is going to be equal to
81 so we now know what 3 to the fourth
is we know what 3 squared is let's just
put it in the expression so this is
going to be equal to 5 times 3 to the
fourth 3 to the fourth is 81 so 5 times
81 minus 3 squared and we have 3 squared
right over here it is equal to 9/5 times
81 minus 9 let's figure out what 5 times
81 is so 81 times 5 1 times 5 is 5 8
times 5 is 40 so this right over here is
405 so it becomes 405 minus 9 so that is
going to be equal to if we're
subtracting 10 it would be 395 but we're
subtracting one less than that so it's
396 and we're done